it's nonsense to say that it's the right
that does cultureal Wars if you look at
the debate between you know on trans
rights is trans rights activists and
feminists these are not conservatives
you look at the issues that happened at
the school in Batley it was very
religious Muslims and a very Pro LGBT
group these are not conservative groups
these things are happening whether or
not conservatives get involved what I
think is that it's only when
conservatives come in with our common
sense that we actually solve the problem
like we did on self ID in Scotland where
everybody was squabbling and we had to
step in and just say no we're not
letting rapists into women's prisons
that's not culture wars that's common
sense